[SPEAKER_00]: As Paul leaves, you get up to go.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Jamis says, word, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Quick word.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, this is more dire than a Lenon.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is what Jeon thinks, and everything that I have said to Paul right now is basically the mind of Prince Jeon, which I would not speak against in front of Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was a messenger on that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think there's something more than the mistake with the code.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the news that you've given me about Toli not being in the foreign district anymore lends it to that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm assuming that it'll be bad there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Possibly Lord Fairwind is a traitor to the Sea Principalities.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is my thought.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it could be worse than that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Meaning the whole island could be seized and he's not a traitor?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, if Lord Fairwind is a traitor, the whole island is seized.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_00]: But even worse...
[SPEAKER_00]: Helm Island is strategically important, not only where it is, but there are things there that are very important to the defense of Monmurg, that if he has control of them, we are very vulnerable to some of the worst enemies we've ever had.
[SPEAKER_00]: How much leeway do I have to do my own thing?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, your leeway is less than my other agents.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm betting gouge onto the ship as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do not act as if you recognize him.
[SPEAKER_00]: He'll be the knife.
[SPEAKER_00]: You are to make sure Paul survives.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, one thing is very important.
[SPEAKER_00]: The helm must be taken.
[SPEAKER_00]: They cannot be left in the hands of anyone that is a traitor or an enemy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there any signal for Horrible Gouge?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: If there's any signal, should we take it or need reinforcements?
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge's mission is basically to make sure that Lord Fairfield is, not Fairfield, but Fairwind is either dead or loyal to the sea principalities.
[SPEAKER_00]: That will be what he is supposed to be doing.
[SPEAKER_00]: The captain of the ship is not to know about anything that you are doing or what Gouge is doing.
[SPEAKER_00]: To him, this is just going to assist another prince.
[SPEAKER_00]: Will Paul have control over the Marines?
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul is there as Prince John's representative.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, John doesn't understand just how tenuous the situation is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, right, but as Prince John's representative, I mean, we're going to have to step into... we're going to have to be received by Lord Fairwind, correct?
[SPEAKER_01]: You would assume.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would assume.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you want me to keep him alive in the middle of a hostile court?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or potentially a hostile court?
[SPEAKER_00]: The guards will be there.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you get to the island, and you get into the helm, and gouge is with you, and you have marines that are loyal to you, I assume that you'll be able to keep both Paul safe and take the place if you need to.
[SPEAKER_00]: What is the complement of troops that Lord Fairwind has?
[SPEAKER_00]: Fairwind has no more than a hundred men on the island.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll let number him two to one.
[SPEAKER_00]: With you and Gouge, your magical abilities, I'm sure you'll be able to neutralize whatever you need.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless assuming that everyone was with him, they might not know.
[SPEAKER_00]: The thing I'm worried about is the Toli Assassin's.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, Gouge has proved very effective against them in the past.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I think that you could be effective as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Understand?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.